the most disturbing clip was when Mehmet  Oz said that local political leaders  should be the ones making decisions  along with patients and doctors about  abortion no they shouldn't it should be  doctors and patients but here is Oz with  a very extreme statement there should  not be involvement from the federal  government and how States decide their  abortion decisions as a physician I've  been in the room when there's some  difficult conversations happening I  don't want the federal government  involved with that at all I want women  doctors local political leaders letting  the Democracy that's always allowed our  nation to thrive to put the best ideas  forward so why do we need politicians in  the room why is it better if they're  local